Amanda's starting off this hour in
Cincinnati hi Amanda how are you I'm
good how are you Dave better than I
deserve what's up I am looking into
starting the baby steps and my concern
is that I have a son who does select
soccer and that cost some money it's not
too expensive but I don't feel like
pulling the rug out from under him just
because I've made mistakes so how would
you suggest I handle that
what does select soccer cost it's only
seven hundred and fifty dollars a year
and that's with all of his uniforms and
everything and your household income is
what just under a hundred thousand okay
and you you have how much debt
seventy-five thousand okay I mean it's
not a deal-breaker it's seven hundred
and fifty dollars
the thing that Sharon and I did when we
were looking at things like that was we
would if we found one thing like that
that we were going to not cut to hit our
debt-free go we had to find something
else we were going to cut deeper okay so
like that means that if you were gonna
cheat and go out to eat once a month now
you're not gotcha
or the if you thought you were gonna do
X now you're not and it's a Attica
instead we're doing select soccer and
how many kids do you have 3
okay and is he the oldest or the
youngest or he thought the oldest okay
alright and well I mean you get yourself
out of debt than the other kids as they
come up can do you can do whatever you
want to do with them in terms of you
know activities and sports and stuff you
can afford to do all of that the thing
that we decided was that all of this is
for fun because I mean Daniel my son
played ice hockey all the way up through
high school we knew at six years old he
was not gonna play in the NHL right we
were pretty sure at that point you know
and so we made decisions to invest in
ice hockey to have fun right not because
we were trying to create a future career
for him reign and that's why we
with the club we did there are a couple
of different options and the one we put
him in is less than half the cost of the
others yeah you know and you know so
parents go bananas on this stuff is my
point
and some of them you know they spend ten
thousand bucks on whatever and you know
in a sport that the kid is never gonna
go pro probably not even gonna get a
scholarship and all you're doing is burn
up the kid and the half your budget but
750 bucks is not the case that you're
fine you know you just got to be but you
do need to look it what it does is it
makes you stop and give pause enough you
called me that's pretty cool yeah you
paused and you went crap I gotta think
about this and so you know just try to
find you a trade-off to in a sense pay
for it we're gonna you know in a sense
we're gonna knock this out hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]